Hello, and welcome to Rawkode Live.
Today's episode, we are going to be hacking
and building a GraphQL
client and a WebAssembly with Rust.
Now before we get started on that, there
is just a little bit of housekeeping.
If you have not subscribed to the YouTube
channel, please do so now. You can click
subscribe, click the bell, and you will get
notifications for all new episodes of Rawkode live
where we'll be exploring the cloud native landscape
and providing learning materials for us all to
get through this mess together.
Also, if you wanna chat and like to
chat, there is a Discord channel available at
Rawkode.chat.
Come and join us and say hello. We
talk about cloud native Kubernetes and all things
in between.
That is it. Nice and easy. Now in
order to help us on our journey today,
I am joined by Connor and Francis. Hello,
both. How are you today?
Doing good.
Well, thank you for for joining me. Do
you want me to start with a little
bit of an introduction? We'll start with you,
Connor, just because you're next to me, and
then Francis, if you wanna take over and
tell us a little bit about yourself.
Yeah. I switched headphones last second there. Can
you still hear me alright? Yes. We can
hear you all good. Okay. Great. Yeah. So
my name is Connor. I I created the
Suborbital family of open source projects.
I I've been a Go developer for a
long time, but, for the last year and
a half or two years, I've been delving
into the world of WebAssembly, trying to build,
cloud native specifically
around WebAssembly.
And so
the Suborbital
family of projects is my way of, you
know, building the the ecosystem around WebAssembly that
I, you know, wanna use as a developer
myself.
My name is Francis. I've been a JavaScript
developer for, I don't know, ten some odd
years.
And I've been making
a lot of serverless
web apps for professionally for a while now.
And so
recently,
I joined Shopify to work on a WebAssembly
platform,
which is a lot of overlap with Suborbital,
and that's how I met Connor. And
I'm a big fan of GraphQL
in serverless environments.
Awesome. Thank you both for sharing.
Yeah. I've gotta say, I'm really excited too.
Like, I I'm gonna be honest. I have
no idea what we're doing today. But whenever
I hear WebAssembly,
GraphQL,
Rust, I'm immediately sold and just wanna start
having some fun.
So, Connor, you had this this idea. Do
you wanna give us a little bit of
a context on what we're gonna do?
Yeah. For sure. So with the, you know,
Suborbital
open source libraries, one of the things that
people have been requesting of me since the
projects have been out in public is the
ability to make calls from a WebAssembly module
running inside of reactor or Atmo, our two
main projects, out to a GraphQL endpoint to
be able to fetch data from an API,
like GitHub's API or Shopify's
API or or whatever. So
I thought,
you know what? I
I've done a little bit of GraphQL in
the past. I'm not the most, you know,
experienced person with it.
So why not, you know, go a little
out of my comfort zone and try to
build this thing
live on the air and and try to
get our WebAssembly modules talking to a GraphQL
back end and see what happens. Now for
people who may not be aware, why isn't
this as easy as just getting an HTTP
client and and using it?
Yeah. So
things get a little tricky
when trying to have a WebAssembly module that
communicates with the outside world because there's a
sandbox around that module that means that, you
know, the the module is not allowed to
just do whatever it wants.
The the host system has to actually grant
it, you know, the ability to
to do anything, really. So we have to
allow
these modules to access the outside world in
a safe way
by actually defining these capabilities
on the host side and then making them
available to the module.
It sounds tricky.
Yeah.
And it it sounds like maybe there's not
a standard there yet, which means, like, that
we can't, like, say, oh, yeah. Turn on
network, and then now they can now it
can make these GraphQL calls.
Or is that not the or or or
is there a reason why we don't wanna
do that?
So there is an up and coming standard
that's being adopted more and more in the
industry called WASI, which is the WebAssembly system
interface,
and more and more capabilities are being added
to that all the time. But,
you know, not everything's available just yet. It's
not fully comprehensive.
And so,
you know, we're
gonna try to build something that would maybe
end up in Wazee one day, this this
interface that we're gonna build today. Yeah. Though,
I think if I remember correctly, the last
time I looked at Wazi, they didn't actually
have BSD socket share. Right? There's there's no
networking.
Yeah. There's there's some proposals in flight that
are currently working on adding all of that
to Wazi,
but not quite yet.
You just like making things difficult for yourself.
Right? And, do we want a full network?
Like like like, is that is that what
we want to expose for this GraphQL project
today?
We don't. We want the host to be
able to have
full control over what these modules are allowed
to do. So the sandbox that I talked
about before,
it's designed to be denied by default. So,
you know, if you just instantiate a WebAssembly
module with absolutely no, you know, preconfigured capabilities,
it can do nothing. It can't, you know,
reach outside of itself in any way, shape,
or form. We want the host to be
able to say exactly what these modules are
allowed to do and
preferably be able to programmatically
configure that when we're running our application. So
we're gonna try to make all of that
happen today.
So for our client,
would it be, would it be an HTTP
client that we were making, or would we
wanna make something GraphQL specific?
So,
Reaktor already has a generic HTTP,
client.
I wanna create something that's very specific to
GraphQL.
Alright.
Yeah.
Okay. I I I think I understand what's
happening here. Right? But because the WebAssembly doesn't
have these parameters baked in, we're gonna be
adding this to the reactor project,
which is gonna expose hooks somehow to the
WebAssembly to be able to make these calls.
Okay.
And now That's right. For anyone that's not
familiar with Suborbital, Atmore, Reactor, etcetera, I'm gonna
show the website here, but can you give
us the the overview?
Absolutely.
So Suborbital
is a collection of open source projects, and,
there are three that I refer to as
the building blocks. So that includes Reaktor
as well as Vector and Grav.
Vector and Grav are networking libraries for Go,
for HTTP servers and async communication.
But Reaktor itself
is a job scheduler, so it's designed to
take tons of jobs as input, and then
it has it'll create workers internally to efficiently
handle all of that work.
And one of the ways that you can
create a reactor worker is with a WebAssembly
module. So that's how we're gonna go about
it today.
And then the you know, I call it
the batteries included
project
is called Atmo, and this builds on top
of those three building blocks to create a
more user friendly version
of, you know, WebAssembly as a cloud native
platform. So it allows you to define
full, you know, server API
applications
with a declarative
file called the directive, and then it uses
WebAssembly modules to actually handle the different things
that you described for that application. So we're
gonna be working at the reactor level. So
it's actually one level down from Atmo because
that's where all of the WebAssembly internals happen.
And then, hopefully, the the goal is that
I'll be able to, you know,
import all of that functionality functionality we build
today into Atmo so that you'll be able
to get the advantages of this GraphQL client
in in either one, whichever you prefer to
use.
That sounds very familiar to what we're building
at Shopify,
which is actually one of the reasons why
we know each other.
Yeah. So Do you wanna share a little
bit about that as well?
Yeah.
So we have the Scripps platform. We just
announced that at Unite
a few days ago, which is Shopify's big
developer conference.
All that stuff's up on YouTube somewhere. Yeah.
You'll be able to find it. Check this,
I think shop shopify.eng,
on Twitter.
And we have this problem
where,
our stores get a lot of traffic, and
we have third party apps. And they have
their web servers, and they run, and they
talk to our API. And that's great. Except
when you get a lot of traffic, they
can fall over if if they're in the
critical path. And so we have to keep
them out of the critical path of, like,
very performance things,
like checkout.
So we have this project, this this app
called Scripts.
You know, if you're a large merchant, you
get to use it to customize your checkout.
And it runs code on our servers
during checkout. And we're able to do that
by sandboxing
using much older technologies than WebAssembly.
Well, we have this new checkout, which we
which we're talking we talked about at at
Unite. It's significantly faster. We can do as
much traffic as we did on the entire
platform during Black Friday, Cyber Monday, like, in
one store, like, the on the new on
the new checkout platform.
And that's like
oh, how was it? Over 200,000
checkouts just a minute or something like that.
So we we want to make sure we
can scale
this customization part too and so enter WebAssembly.
And so we wanna take scripts
compiled into WebAssembly and execute those to customize
our platform, you know, for your stores, you
know, during checkout. And honestly,
I wanna see a world where you write
your app,
to run on Shopify's infrastructure,
you know. And it's not you know, it's
like our APIs are APIs, but, like like,
WebAssembly can run anywhere. And it can run,
as we've talked about, safely, you know, in
sandbox. So so anyway, this there's just a
lot of overlap here. And the the better
the better the ecosystem and the better the
tools we have, the better the tools we
can provide, you know, and and capabilities we
can add to our platform. So, anyway, that
just makes me very happy.
Awesome. Well, it sounds like you are both
extremely qualified for today's task at hand, so
I am gonna sit back and watch.
And I'll do my best to probe the
questions as we go.
Let's get started.
What's what's what's step one here, Connor?
So
we're gonna start in the reactor code base,
and there's actually three
layers that we will need to concern ourselves
with.
There's
the actual
code to make the GraphQL request.
That's step one. Step two is defining the
interface
that the host
exposes
to the module and making sure that the
module can provide all of the information that
it needs to provide.
And then the third step will be
actually
switching gears over into,
Rust
to actually consume that host API. So we're
gonna add, you know, some capabilities to the
Suborbital rust library that can actually call into
that host function and take advantage of of
what we've built.
My Go is not any good.
My Rust is okay.
It's definitely We're all here to learn from
each other. GraphQL APIs
APIs
for this.
Right.
Cool. So we're gonna start in the capabilities
dot go file inside of the RT package
if you wanna open your tree up there.
Or you can oh, are you able to
follow me? Oh, that's even better. Yes. It's
been a while since I've used this fancy
Versus Code plugin, so this is awesome. Alright.
So right here is
what we call the capability struct. So this
is a collection
of
things that WebAssembly modules are allowed to utilize
when they're running inside of Reactor. So as
you can see, we've got a couple here.
We've got a logger. We've got an HTTP
client. We've got a file source to access
host files, and then we've got a cache.
So
we're gonna be essentially adding to this list
here, and we're gonna be adding a GraphQL
provider to this set of capabilities.
So
we can maybe start by taking a look
at
the simplest one, which is the logger so
that we can you know? Actually, the logger
is not a good example. Let's look at
the HTTP client.
The the logger just provides a logger object.
That's not as fun.
So it's really quite straightforward.
The the
the interface is just exposing
one function, and that is, you know, take
in an HTTP request
and provide either an HTTP response or an
error.
And because Go has its entire, you know,
networking stack completely built in, that amounts to
one line, you know, to to call the
the HTTP built in clients. Right?
But,
you know, this
part is only,
you know, the it's actually the most boring
part of what we're gonna do today. You
know, making the GraphQL call from Go is
is not actually gonna be the hard part.
The hard part is going to be defining
that interface between
the host and the WebAssembly module. So,
you know, this is going to be somewhat
similar to what we build today to make
a GraphQL
call,
but let's take a look at the you
know, what that interface would look like so
that we can get an idea of what
we're in for.
So Can I talk a bit about what
GraphQL expects?
Yeah.
How do we do that? Or we wanna
talk at a lower level first?
Yeah. If you wanna give maybe an overview
of what GraphQL is is designed to be
used for and and how maybe it's structured,
that would be great.
So
people always get mad when I make this
comparison, but have you ever used SOAP?
You know, so if
you have, you'll you'll understand. But, basically, there
is an HTTP endpoint you can post to
it. Sometimes you can get to it.
GraphQL actually doesn't care how you get to
it. It wants a couple things. It wants
a string that is a query.
It wants
a a hash that is your variables for
that query, if any. It wants an operation
name because your query can define multiple operations.
And it's
I was actually just looking at some other
stuff. There are extensions. So some servers will
take other inputs as well. There's a whole
file upload extension, all sorts of things. But
at the end of the day, it is
a couple things in,
mainly query variables and operation name. And then
you get an object out. And they don't
even declare it has to be JSON.
99%
of these things are JSON. I've seen seen
message pack and other stuff.
But but that has
two keys, data and error. And so you
get query variables operation name in and data
and errors out.
And
and that is, like, the basic API. People
took take this, put it over WebSockets, made
GraphQL subscriptions.
They've also taken this, put it in a
GET request, and now you can have cacheable
kinda, you know, GET, you know, for query
only, you know, GET request kind of things.
And there's all there's a whole slew of
extensions from Apollo and and a dozen other
companies out there trying to trying to make
a big in GraphQL.
But
the very basics, which is probably where we
should start, are those are those three inputs
and two outputs.
Absolutely.
So we're probably gonna be doing something fairly
similar to this today, which is why I
wanna kind of use it as the example.
So this is a generic HTTP
interface.
So, you know, where we, you know, we
started with that HTTP
client, this is the actual Go
implementation
of the HTTP client, but then we need
to define
the
you know, how the WebAssembly module will tell
the host that it wants to make one
of these requests.
So
we'll take a look at,
you know, this portion of the reactor project.
This is where we define
that interface.
So one of the quirks of WebAssembly is
that you can't take a go variable
and pass it and expect that Rust understands
that go variable.
You need to serialize
any information that you wanna pass in between
the module and the host so that, you
know, they can understand each other. Now, again,
WebAssembly is,
is evolving, and so there are some standards
that are being put in place,
to be able to actually natively share
memory
in the way that would be, you know,
maybe a little bit more efficient and a
little bit, easier to understand. But as it
stands today, we're gonna be doing some serializing
in order to pass information between. So
in Reaktor, when you expose a host function
to the WebAssembly module,
we define it, and it looks something like
this here. So the fetch URL host call
takes in a whole list of parameters, and
I'll kind of go through them each. So
first, we ask, okay. What's the HTTP method
that we're gonna be doing? And that is
a set of constants. You know, we either
gonna do a a get or a post
or a patch or delete, and those map
to numbers one through four.
So that's number one. Why?
Why
Why do they have
Yeah. Because That'll take us right. Want to,
yeah, we wanna minimize the amount of serializing
and deserializing that we have to do there
to be a little bit more efficient. So
anything that we can map down to a
simpler data type is usually a good idea.
Okay. So there's no there's no restrictions on
on the kinds of data types, though. So
if we really needed a string, we could
we could get we could get that string,
and I'm assuming that's what the URL how
the URL pointer works.
Kind of. So WebAssembly
naturally
does not have a string type. You can't
define a string.
But individual programming languages do have a string
type. So what do we do there? How
do we get a string to kind of
traverse that boundary between the host and the
module? And what we in order to do
that, we write the string to a particular
piece of memory, and then we pass a
pointer to that memory,
you know, in either direction so that, you
know, you know where to find it. So
when the when the WebAssembly module asks the
host to fetch a URL,
it is going to include
a pointer to the string in memory
where it can find that information, and then
it's gonna tell us the size of that
memory as well so that when the host
receives this function call, I'll I'll cover in
a second how it can actually go and
ask the module, hey. Give me this memory
at this pointer
so that I can figure out what URL
you were trying to tell me about.
And then we do the same thing for
the HTTP body.
So it's it's these kind of pairs
of of
data types that we're gonna be passing in
order to to accomplish this. It's a little
bit kludgy,
but,
you know, the the
advancement of the WebAssembly standard is gonna mean
we don't necessarily have to do this anymore
once,
once things get a little bit more you
know, a little bit further along.
So Now can I guess this is completely
safe to point to arbitrary places in memory?
Not always.
So
WebAssembly defines linear memory.
So there is actually
globally
exported blocks of memory that the host is
allowed to dig into and and grab. So
we have to define a contract between the
module and the host to say, you know,
you you you should be looking at this
piece of memory in order to safely, you
know, communicate with me. You can't just go
arbitrarily,
you know, poking around in there. And so
part of what Reactor does for you is
kind of handles that all for you to
ensure that it's be being done safely, and
and you're not just arbitrarily
messing around in the in the memory of
the WebAssembly module.
Makes sense.
Yeah.
So in order to reconstruct
that memory into a string, we have a
couple of, you know, helper functions that are
inside of Reactor. So there's this read memory
helper function here that allows us to take
that pointer
and the, you know, the size variable and
actually
pull that information out of the WebAssembly module
as it's running. So the the WebAssembly module
exposes its global memory to us,
and we can use that you know, the
pointer to access the data at a particular
point,
and then we can read the data to
a certain
endpoint.
And then, you know, because of the interface
we've defined, we're interpreting it as a string.
So once we,
you know, once we have read that memory
out of the WebAssembly module, we convert it
to a string to so that we can
use it as a URL, which is the
the thing that, you know, this function is
actually attempting to do.
Cool.
Any
any thoughts or questions from anyone at this
point?
So I've learned a lot in the last
five years.
I think it's really cool. So if I
understand this correctly, we have to define a
Go interface
that kind of
prescribes how
the Wasm side of things knows how to
make this request by
enumerating
values. Like, maybe it's a GraphQL query as
a one, a GraphQL mutation as a two,
and then we have the ability to use
pointers and memory space to actually squeeze in
the query
and then execute it and then do the
same in reverse to get the result back.
It's kind of where I think we're headed.
That's exactly right. So you you kind of
you got to the end
pretty quickly there in that. What we're gonna
end up doing is we are going to
write
the
results back into the WebAssembly module's memory. Once
we've completed the GraphQL
request,
we're gonna use this helper function here, which
actually writes
the
the memory. And then
then the module
once the function call completes, the module will
then go and read that memory to reconstitute
the
the results on the other side. So,
you'll see this this, acronym FFI,
throughout the code base,
and FFI stands for foreign function interface. So
when we talk about crossing that boundary
between the host and the module, we call
that an FFI, a foreign function interface, so
that it it's basically the the idea of
how do we translate
the function call across that boundary and make
it so that it's a, you know, properly
defined
host call, essentially.
So when you see that f five terminology
host
and module. Yeah. So if I if I
had to take from context,
host is
the the the fully
you know, the process is running on an
operating system. It's the thing that executes the
Wasm module.
Is that is that correct?
Yes. That's right. So Reaktor,
you know, when you when you use the
Reaktor
library
and you run a Go program that uses
the Reaktor
library,
that process
is the host. And so because it's just
a Go program, it has access to the
whole wide world of anything, you know, network
files,
whatever it wants to do.
And then the module, which is the WebAssembly
program that we have compiled,
gets loaded into Reaktor as a child or
as a guest,
and then that guest module is allowed to
communicate with Reactor over this FFI
that we define here. So this fetch URL
function is just one of the
FFI
functions available to the guest module. And
you said something
that that, and it looks like, actually, we
have some questions in chat. But, but you
said something that maybe is important, maybe it's
not. You said when the request completes, we
tell Wasm.
Does this mean that there's some sort of
asynchronous
ex exposure to Wasm, like, from our Wasm
code?
So
everything in WebAssembly is synchronous.
There is not yet the concept of threads
or asynchronous
execution in WebAssembly. So this is all actually
happening
in sequence. So the the order in which
things happen is
reactor
loads the module
and starts to execute it, then the module
makes a function call to the host. The
host performs some kind of
some kind of action, like making an HTTP
call, And then the host relinquishes control back
to the the module where it can then
receive the results of that function.
And so our code in the module says,
hey. Get me this GraphQL API, and it's
like, oh, I got it. Thanks. You know,
it just gets it synchronously.
That's exactly right. And yeah.
And and because WebAssembly doesn't support any kind
of threading,
Reaktor
kind of helps you with that. Because Reaktor
is able to run
dozens or hundreds or thousands of WebAssembly modules
all at the same time, you can actually
almost achieve threading by just running many copies
of that WebAssembly module all at the same
time. So Reactor helps you do that by
creating pools
of workers to accomplish
different tasks in a multithreaded
way.
Alright. Can we tackle a couple of questions
from Reza, and then we can get into
some Do it. Coding here. So Reza asked,
are you using tiny Go or Go?
So
for the host, for Reaktor itself, that is
written in Go proper.
And if you wanted to run Go code
as one of the guest modules as an
actual WebAssembly module, that's when you would probably
reach for TinyGo because TinyGo has a really
good WebAssembly tool chain,
that is quite honestly better than the regular
Go tool chain in in a lot of
ways.
And there's a a follow-up that says, how
do you know which memory space needs to
be accessed? Are there any tools?
Yeah. So,
technically, WebAssembly modules can export
multiple
memories.
It's an interesting concept that
I haven't fully taken advantage of yet, honestly,
but there is kind of a main memory,
a
global memory that is exported by every WebAssembly
module. And so for Reaktor's case, at least,
we only use that main memory module. But
maybe in the future, I'll find some use
case for having multiple kind of individual memory
exports.
Does does this mean it can export its
memory safely?
As in, like, if it doesn't trust the
the host?
Yeah. So it's it's
usually, the the trust relationship is in the
other direction. So, usually, it's the host mistrusting
the module.
There is, you know, not it's not really
designed for a module to mist mistrust the
host.
I'm sure there's ways you could do that.
Smarter folks than myself would need to figure
out a way to do that properly.
Alright. Well, I think, Reza, you'll hopefully, as
we dive into this and write a little
bit of code that the pointers and size
will become a little bit more apparent to
you. So let's let's move forward and get
some code work. Yeah.
Alright. Actually, I think I got an answer
there.
I believe there's just a fixed pointer size
in in WASM. Is that right? There's a
fixed memory space and a fixed pointer size
that everybody needs use.
Yeah. So the the fun part about WebAssembly
is that so I mentioned that it's linear
memory.
So memory in a WebAssembly module is essentially
just a gigantic array,
and you can access that array at different
points. And so when you pass a pointer
from a WebAssembly module to the host, you're
basically just telling the host, hey. Access my
gigantic array at this particular index and read
it for this number of bytes.
And so it's it's actually pretty cool.
Great. Alright.
Oh, and I guess we should take a
quick look at the the host code first
before we move on. So I wanna show
kind of the matching
the matching WebAssembly
internal
call. So we looked at the, you know,
fetch URL call on the go side.
But if we switch over to the Rust
side of things,
this is going to be the code that
gets actually compiled and put inside of the
WebAssembly module. So in the Suborbital
Rust library, we define, you know, an HTTP
module. And inside of that module, we actually
define an external function
with the exact same
signature as the host function. So when we
are inside of the module,
we can call this function,
and it will directly map
to the host's version of this function. So
when
this code
calls fetch URL,
what it's really doing is asking the host
to run
this host
version of itself.
So that's how that communication
happens,
and we'll probably dive into that more in
a in a little while. But,
yeah, we can we can choose either Rust
or AssemblyScript.
Whichever we wanna go with today, I'm I'm
I'm cool with.
My voice actually Rust. Yeah.
I think that's the the more fun option
for sure.
Alright. So step one here to define the
host interface then?
Yeah. That's right. So we're gonna create one
of these capabilities
that is just Go code to make a
a GraphQL endpoint. So I'm gonna create a
GraphQL
dot go file,
and we're gonna start from scratch. We're doing
this
from nothing. We we have written no code
yet.
So this lives in a package called r
cap, which just stands for reactor capabilities,
and we have to get started here. So
we want to start
with this do one of you wanna to
to to to do this part? I'm happy
to let one of you type.
I think I think, like,
just to like, deciding the inputs and the
outputs
might be an interesting thing. Because I know
how we would do it,
like, from Rust. If I were to make
if I were to have a Rust function,
right, a method that that that, like, takes
GraphQL input and output,
you know, I I would
I know what that I want that to
look like, and I'm curious how to translate
that to our
host guest
you know, our host module interface.
Cool. So why why don't we sketch it
out in pseudocode here, and then we can
actually get to writing the proper Go code?
I'm wondering if
this is,
if you're seeing this. I got I got
Copilot running on my machine. No. You're not
seeing this, but it's really crazy. The stuff
they're trying to do for me.
Okay. So I I know where you have
a query. I know a query is a
string. Right? Yep. And
I know we're gonna have variables.
And I know variables
is going to be
it is gonna be a object, a hash.
So this is gonna be like a JSON
object.
Really though, like, everything altogether and and we
have an optional operation name,
which is also a string.
And I guess variables is also optional. So,
like, this is my TypeScript showing. But
the whole thing actually is gonna get to
JSON. And 99% of the GraphQL servers out
there. So so maybe our only input is
a string.
And I don't know. So I
think the only thing we're missing here is
the endpoint. I need to know where this
thing is going. Yeah.
Now one of the questions will be, do
we want
yeah. Yeah. You're right.
So
the
the question is, do we want to instantiate
the object with a predefined endpoint, or do
we want the module to be able to
pass it, you know, whichever endpoint it wants
when we make the the host call? We
don't have to decide now.
Cool.
So we're going to wanna create some a
Go struct to kind of help us along
here.
So we'll start with
GraphQL
client
stretch,
and we're gonna it's gonna wanna have an
HTTP client as, you know, one of its
internal fields.
But other than that, I mean, there's not
a whole lot that we need to add
here. So
we're gonna make sure we comment our code
well.
Is
a GraphQL
capability?
I can't type
for
reactor
modules.
Great.
So
we're gonna oh, yeah. That's right. So date
errors are as an array. Right? Okay. You're
way ahead of me. Yeah.
Awesome. Sorry.
So
I think the first thing that I would
do when I'm approaching this is I would,
you know, take you know, we we've defined
pretty well what our input is here, and
we should define what it is we're sending
to the the GraphQL server. So I usually
start with a, you know, a request type.
So if we define a GraphQL request,
type that includes
our query,
which is a string,
and that goes out to JSON of the
string.
And we include our variables,
which is a,
in in Go, it's called a map, so
a map of strings to strings,
and that will go into JSON as variables,
I believe, if I'm not mistaken.
And then that operation
name
operation
is a string, and that goes to JSON
as operation
name with that capitalization,
I think.
Yep. And since it's optional, we're gonna add
this omit empty
directive
here so that if we don't provide one,
it's just not gonna include it in that
JSON output.
Variables
to is you can omit empty.
Oh, yes. You're right.
So
keep our code nice and well commented.
Is a request to a GraphQL
endpoint.
Cool. So we've kind of defined now. We're
gonna be sending this to the server, and
now let's define what we're gonna get back.
So a GraphQL
response
is
looks something like this. So data is I'm
assuming that's gonna be bytes.
It's gonna be a JSON object
or a null or JSON null.
I see. Okay. So then I guess it
would probably be a map
string interface. That's usually how I define just
a some unknown JSON blob,
and that is an actual key
called data. Right?
Yeah.
And the response? Great. And then our errors
are an array of
the array of an object that looks like
this. Is that right?
Correct.
Message path and type? Cool. So we'll probably
wanna define that as its own,
its own structure here. So if we define
a GraphQL error
and
oops. I gotta tell you, it's not standard.
The the message in the path is standard.
Every
server gives a little extra.
Gotcha.
Cool. So we'll define what that GraphQL error
looks like, and we'll define,
the path
JSON path.
And then we'll say that the errors is
an array of GraphQL.
Man, I need Copilot to give me better
better suggestions
here.
You can thank Copilot for the definition of
errors there. You just did it.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, there's no there's no colon there.
Okay.
How's that look? Am I missing anything?
No. The former architect then, so I can
get
That's what I know if my code works.
That's right. One of the for anybody who's
not familiar with writing Go, there's a tool
called GoFmt or Go FMT
that runs every time you save a file,
and it will apply a standard set of
formatting to your code. So, for example, all
the spacing here, lining up these these, you
know, back ticks so that they look pretty,
that's all done automatically for you. So it
makes you, you know, it makes your code
even prettier than
what you're what I'm usually,
willing to put effort in for.
Alright.
So I think
just I I'm not sure if data and
errors are both always there at all times.
I'm looking up the response format, like, spec
right now. But if that doesn't really matter
as much, we can figure that out later.
Yeah. It's it's never a bad idea to
include Omid empty. There is no, no harm
in in doing that.
Alright. Let's keep our code commented.
It's a GraphQL
response.
Yes.
Data should,
According to the spec data, it should always
be there, but sometimes it's null. If there
were errors, it'll be null.
Gotcha.
Alright. Got a comment from null saying we
have a typo and our message JSON definition.
Message
JSON. Ah, you are correct. Good catch. That
would've that would've been real annoying when
it goes to unmarshall the JSON, and we
find that our message is always empty.
Good catch. Good catch. Alright. So
those are inputs and outputs. So now we
need to actually, you know, define that function
that will do it for us. So we're
gonna create a function that operates on the
GraphQL client,
and
the HTTP client calls it do. So I'm
just gonna call it do as well. And
so this is where I'm
maybe gonna ask Francis what the best,
you know, the best practice is here. Do
we want to have query and mutation defined
as specific types,
or
what do you think is the best thing
to do there? No.
So your your query document can include mutations
and queries
and, you know, anything
else you wanna
your server might support. So so I think
the difference,
in the in the result is is nothing.
The difference in the input is nothing. So
I I don't see them as being different
method.
I see. So you actually you actually specify
that inside of your query string. Is that
right?
Exactly. Cool.
So then I guess we'll just start with
of
you'll find a lot of and I I
don't know if this translates for us. In,
like, the React world, all the hooks, you'll
find different, like, methods for query and mutation.
Only because queries you probably wanna execute right
away, where mutations you wanna choose to execute
later. Like, you wanna set them up and
then use them. And
that might be the only reason we wanna
do that, but I I don't I don't
see why this interface would would would include
that kind of concept.
I didn't know that. That's really useful. I
thought that you have to send queries over
a GET and, like, mutations over a post.
That's just what I've seen in other libraries,
but today I've learned seen different
things in different places.
Under the hood, mutations
are actually a mutation in the input and
then a query. And so it's actually, like
like, it's like, at the end of the
day, they're all the output is always a
query. You know? So it's the same kinda
same operation in GraphQL.
Oh, Reza pointed out another typo here. This
is not gonna be called string in the
JSON. This is gonna be called query.
Alright. The audience are confused. Right? My fingers
yeah. Sometimes my fingers work faster than my
brain.
We need the high and high level code.
Exactly.
Alright. So this function is gonna either return
a GraphQL,
response,
or it's going to return a GraphQL error.
Now in Golang, I usually don't like to
return a concrete
struct type as an error. So we're gonna
return the generic error type, and we're gonna
actually make GraphQL error conform to that type
by just giving it the one method that
it means. So
In which case the graph our graph will
response
doesn't need to include errors,
or does it?
Right?
Good point. I think it does. Actually returning
that directly. No. I think you're right. So
what what I would what I would tend
to do is that if this is populated
in the response, we would just, return an
error here and tell them to look inside
of the errors array. So you you make
a good point. We're not returning this directly.
We actually have an array of them inside
here. So, yeah, that's that's a good point.
I believe it's a choice
of the two sometimes, if there is an
error in execution,
to include partial data
as well. So a field can error, and
you still get the other fields. I see.
And so I see. So you can still
have, like, a usable response object. Okay. Cool.
So,
I guess, for now, let's include the endpoints,
in
the
in the actual function parameters. We may choose
to
pull this out and make it specific to
the client object later, but for now, let's
just let you pass both, in one go.
So
for those of you who are like myself
and are fairly new to GraphQL,
it's it's really nice that GraphQL
queries are really just HTTP requests. So we
can get away with, you know, using Go's
built in HTTP client to to accomplish a
lot of what we wanna do here today.
So
we're gonna build
an HTTP request.
We're going to send that HTTP request off
to the endpoint that's defined here, and then
we're gonna parse the the response. So to
start, we're going to create that request object
by using the HTTP
package,
and that has a new request method inside
of it. So
here is where that that spec ambiguity
can
maybe cause us a little bit of pain.
So we need to choose our HTTP method
here.
And so I'm gonna
Would it be simpler for us to assume
it's a post with no headers
just to get it going and then add
it in later?
I think that's the right call. So we
can start with, http dot method post here.
And, yeah, like you said, that's the simplest
way, and then maybe we can make it
fancier later if we have time.
So then we're gonna pass in that URL.
So this is going to be our endpoint,
and then we're gonna pass in our body.
So we need to actually construct that body.
In the in Go, we use this it
it it accepts this IO dot reader type,
which is an interface that just, you know,
expects you to be able to read data
from it. So we need to build something
that conforms to that interface. So in order
to do that, we need to
figure out what's gonna go in it. So,
we're taking in, you know, the query string,
which is going to be placed inside of
this field in the GraphQL request.
So we need to actually build this request
object before we can kind of continue. So,
let's create a request object that is of
type GraphQL
request,
and we're gonna stick some data into it.
So the query is going to be the
query that was passed into us here.
And then,
to start, I think our variables
can be,
empty.
So we'll just create a map string to
string that has no data. And then the
operation name,
I think it also optional. So, actually, we'll
we'll exclude that because it has that omit
empty operation
on it. Technically, we exclude both of these,
but, you know, just for illustration purposes.
So then in Go, when we wanna take
a a struct and create JSON from it,
we use the JSON package. So we're gonna
call
sorry.
We're gonna say that the request bytes
is JSON
dot Marshall,
which is the equivalent of JavaScript to JSON
or JSON dot stringify. I can't even remember
what it is at this point.
And we're gonna pass in that request object.
Yeah.
And then we're going to check our errors
here
so that if, you know, the JSON was
poorly formed, we could catch that before we
try to send to the server.
So this this errors dot wrap for anybody
who's never seen this before. This is this
is something pretty
unique to go, I think, where we wanna
make sure that we have some indication of
where this error originated.
So what we're doing is we're taking the
error that came out of this function call,
and we're wrapping it into in an in
a message saying where that,
kind of failure came from. It just is,
a habit that I've picked up. Whether or
not it's standard practice, I don't know, but
that's just, how I've always done things.
This is this is actually a feature that's
coming to JavaScript pretty soon too.
I think probably because of Go. But just,
like, adding that more context and keeping the
original error behind or having multiple errors that
you wanna send as one. Like like, it's
just a common pattern. And so I'm happy
it's happy it's got language support here.
Mhmm. For sure.
Cool. So now we've got bytes, a variable
containing bytes, which is our JSON. So we're
going to as that last parameter
in our, request builder, we're gonna use the,
bytes dot new buffer, which is
it takes those bytes and loads it into
that IO dot reader, interface we were looking
at before. So the rec bytes will go
in there, and now we have a request.
So we're gonna do the same thing.
We're gonna do a similar error checking for
this call,
but instead, we're gonna say fail to request.
Request.
And then,
we have a request object. So we can
take a quick look at what that looks
like for anybody who's unfamiliar with Go.
The HTTP
request in Go is just a method
and the URL that you're making that request
to, a bunch of stuff that I don't
care about,
some headers for the HTTP request, a body,
which will be the request body for our
post request,
and then, you know, some other metadata like
content length and some
you know, if you want and wanted to
use a a form request, you could do
that,
multipart,
etcetera. So lots of fun stuff in there
that you can take advantage of, but we're
doing pretty a pretty basic, requests today. So
we're really just gonna be including
a, buffer
that includes our request.
And then we're gonna want to add a
header. So
just just to specify the content type, I
believe that's
standard practice, if I'm not if I'm not
mistaken with GraphQL.
So for the Application JSON. Dot header.
Yeah. So we're gonna add a
content type.
Now I've seen conflicting reports. I've seen application
JSON, and I've seen application GraphQL. So do
you wanna set me straight on what I
should be using here?
I mean,
it's not in spec. It's whatever the server
wants. Application JSON will work everywhere as far
as I understand it, though.
Gotcha. Because, like, most most clients are setting
that because they're sending JSON.
Understood.
Understood. Alright. I think the application slash
GraphQL is if you want to send the
raw GraphQL video, right, without actually
Oh. Change that to JSON.
Just got Without wrapping it in in this
struct, you mean?
Well, yeah. Like, you know, so, like, a
GraphQL
GraphQL request would be, like, query
I can't remember the exact syntax, but all
post name.
Like, you can send it without JSON without
converting that to JSON as GraphQL, depending on
the server of ours.
Got it. But we don't need to worry
about that today. Let's just do JSON.
Yeah. Fair enough. Alright.
So then what we're gonna wanna do is
we're gonna actually wanna make that request. So
we're gonna do
we're gonna take the, HTTP
client that we added to our GraphQL client,
and we're gonna actually,
use it to make a an actual request.
So we're gonna do, g dot do.
Oh, that's gonna be confusing. We should actually
call this client to prevent
making any mistakes.
If we have a do request do function
on this and a do function on the
HTTP client, we could run into some issues
here. So we'll do g dot client dot
dude just to be very specific about what
we're what we're trying to do here, and
we're gonna pass in that HTTP request object
that we created up here.
So we'll do the same
error checking
right here.
We're going to return no
and
failed to do,
and then we're gonna do something with this
response. So that response
contains
hopefully, if everything goes correctly, that is gonna
retain something that looks like this.
So we want to actually take the raw
response,
and we wanna load that data
into that struct. So we're gonna create,
we'll call it GQL response,
and it is going to be a, GraphQL,
response
object.
And then we're going to use that same
JSON package as before, But instead of marshal,
which takes a struct and turns it into
JSON, we're gonna do the opposite. We're gonna
use unmarshal, which takes JSON and turns it
into a struct. So,
we're going to unmarshal
the,
response dot body
into
the GQL response.
And we're gonna be a good
good best practice for Go is we're going
to
we're going to close
that
that body
similarly to how you would wanna close a
file. We're gonna close that body,
when we're done with it.
And we're gonna check the error on that
as well.
Of course.
There's a lot of this this this this
stanza. It repeats itself a lot in Go
code.
I've gotta say, I'm really impressed that you
haven't like, whenever I write Go code these
days, there's 50% go and 50% rust, and
I always have to go back and fix
it.
You've not typed f m once or
That's me when I'm writing Rust code. I
will very often accidentally write Go code while
I'm writing Rust. Yeah. I was writing I
just realized stop print or print l n
in the wrong language all the time. It's
so annoying. Yeah. I just realized we we
missed a step. We need to we need
to do response.
We need to do
response JSON
is IU tilde read all
response dot body. We need to actually extract
the raw bytes out of that
first.
I should really put this error not nil
into a into some kind of snippet.
Yeah.
I've become co pilot.
Use snippets. Use snippets.
You're gonna have some copyrighted
code in there.
Alright. So
now we have we've made the request.
We have read the response out of out
of here, and we're gonna actually do the
right thing here. So we've we've read the
we've read the raw bytes out of that
response, and then we're taking the JSON package
to actually convert that JSON
into the GraphQL
response type. So if we've gotten this far
and nothing go has gone wrong,
a, I'll be shocked if it works on
the first try, and b, it means that
we're done. So we can actually return
that GQL response and a nil error to
say that we are done.
So, yeah, Reza pointed out that
h ttp dot new request is not available
in TinyGo, and that's exactly correct. So because
when we talked about earlier that WebAssembly doesn't
have a native networking stack at all, Pretty
much the native
the native network library for any programming language
won't just work out of the box inside
of WebAssembly. So that's why we're creating,
you know, these interfaces so that we can
basically ask the host to do these complicated
networking tasks on behalf of the WebAssembly module
instead of trying to do it from within
the module itself.
Alright. What is this complaining about?
No custom. Oh, that's right. In order to
in order to do proper JSON marshaling, we
need to export all of these fields.
That's something that I always forget.
That was a a comment earlier from which
I didn't understand, and now I do.
They told us our struct fields aren't exported.
Yes. That's that's probably why it had the
yellow squigglies before.
Alright. Cool.
So I think, we have got a
very basic,
GraphQL client here. So
do we wanna try it out and see
if it actually works? No. That's good. Let's
finish.
Alright. Well, it's really nice hanging out, though.
Like, are you sure? You want him to
stay in here?
Let's let's do it. Let's let's see if
this works. Well, do we have a GraphQL
API out there that will take an unauthenticated
post and give us some data?
I do. I think David. I think David
might have something. Yeah. Cool.
So I'm gonna quickly create a
QL client. I'm gonna quickly create a constructor
for us here,
and then we can get to it. So
we're gonna create that GraphQL
client. We're gonna call,
h t t dot default client, and then
we're gonna return g, and that is going
to be
the
GraphQL
client we're looking for. So now we've got
a constructor to actually create this client,
and we can actually try to use it
in
graph.
Why is GraphQL
client so hard for me to type?
I'm not quite sure. Okay. So did one
of you wanna try
try actually using
this thing?
I like
I like to create start?
I like to create a tester file here
with a main dot go,
and
I will I will create your
I'll create your main function for you, and
then I'm gonna let one of you two,
go crazy and and It's gonna have to
be you. I don't know. Go.
David, I think you need to take a
stab at this.
I wish I was paying more attention, but
sure.
Let's go out there. Pokemon test servers are
the best.
Thank you, Rizzo.
Alright. So we wanna be able to consume
this new GraphQL client. Right?
Mhmm. That's right.
So
we should be able to
import
from the r cap package that
so it'll be r cap dot new GraphQL
client.
Mhmm.
So for Go, we're gonna need the fully
qualified import path.
Oh, yeah.
Alright. Cap. Just like that. So that should
be cool.
And it doesn't return the matter. Yep. It
just returns the thing. So now I can
do Yeah. Find dot
do.
Yeah. And I can call my endpoint.
Yeah.
And I can pass in my
query,
which I'm gonna jump over here and get
one.
But this is it. This is an API
that
I've been I'm I'm trying to move all
of the episode data and stuff like that
to get hub and then publish this API
so that it can be consumed by anyone.
So there's not a lot in it, but
there's enough to get it started. And then
as we've got in the comments, there is
Pokemon APIs we can use to
Yeah. Yeah. If we wanna get into the
Pokemon APIs, I'm definitely interested in that. Alright.
So why don't we just pull down profiles
and then we'll grab my name.
Make sure it come down. Pokemon APIs are
the best hello world of GraphQL.
Not to do apps? I thought it was
all about the to do app. No?
No. They're better. So much cooler data.
Yeah. So is this correct?
That looks about right to me. So that
do function is gonna return
either a response or an error, so you
gotta assign
something to it.
Exactly.
That's right.
So then we can do the good old
error check, and we can see if this
thing if this thing works.
That's
the right that's exactly right. So then
if it is
if it is successful,
then we should be able to maybe just
print response dot data or something like that.
Let's see what happens.
Data. Data would have yeah. There you go.
Okay.
That's not complaining on my end, so why
don't we give it a try? Print
in the error. Print the error.
Oh, yeah. We should print the error. That's
right on on run 21 there.
Oh. Actually, you know, we can we can
do an alternative to OS dot exit. We
can do log dot fatal. Fatal allows you
to actually pass in the error as a
as a
as a parameter. Alright.
Shall we try to run this?
Let's do it. Yeah. Let's
you do you a share terminal? Go tool
chain?
I don't know. I haven't I haven't used
this share thing in a long time. Do
you wanna try to pop one up? Yeah.
There you go. Do you have the Go
tool chain installed? Yeah. You only think of
us It's running on your machine.
Yeah. You should be able to run it
here, and
and we should be check. Show you?
If you use the same terminal, we have
two right now. So don't type in your
first one. I guess I could just click
it. Oh. No. Wait. That's my terminal. Yeah.
If you click in the shared terminal.
Okay.
I don't even see that. Let me find
it here. Oh, there it is.
Shared terminal.
Is that
Yeah. There we go. Oh. ASPS. There we
go. Alright. Cool.
This is awesome. I love this live share
thing. Alright. So we're going to
we're gonna go run this thing. So we're
gonna do our cap slash tester slash main
dot go,
and we're gonna see if this works.
Hey. Look at that. Fast.
It worked. We're getting some data. Even
though you had me tape it. Oh, that's
That just goes to show that the library
is really solid.
I didn't ship it.
Can we do this again? Let's make a
let's make an error. I wanna see what
the errors look like. So if I do
all profiles
z z z z z, I save that.
Yeah.
And then I And then I'll I'll
extend it again.
Oh,
it looks like it didn't,
it didn't detect the errors, so we that
that seems like a bug in our,
in our end.
Well, why don't we check out what's going
on there? I'm curious. We wanna follow-up. We
may get one of several errors here. We
might get a 200 response with an with
the errors,
array. We might get a 400 response with
the errors array. We might get a 500
response
with the errors array,
or or we may get nothing. You know?
Right. Alright. Well, we can we can account
for all those. Do you wanna follow my
cursor again, David? We can try to add
a little bit of robustness to this thing.
Following?
Yeah. There we go. So what we'll do
is once we've gotten this response back and
we've kind of read the the data out
of it, we can actually go and add
some extra checking here.
Do you wanna deselect that text maybe?
There we go.
So what we can do is we can
say if the response
dot status code
is not a 200
or we can say is greater than 299,
that's what I usually like to do,
then,
we can return,
the
oh, actually, we wanna do this after we've
parsed the, the JSON. Okay. So the problem
we never got the error there was because
the GraphQL server is actually saying 200 okay
and the errors and the response,
which is why we never got the error
handling. Got it. Exactly. And so If if
errors is not null or undefined or whatever,
that's when we know we have a GraphQL
error. There still might be GraphQL data, but
that's that's when we know something bad one
happened, like, hands down across every server.
So what we'll do here is we'll say
else
if the GQL response dot errors
were in fact did we make that Omid
empty? I can't remember. We did. It's empty.
So we'll say
we'll say if it's not nil and
the length of it
is
greater than zero,
we will
return the response and an error
saying that the
graph
QL I cannot type those words in that
particular order for some reason.
GraphQL
returned
errors,
something like that. So that Would you really
make that an else if, or would it
just be two ifs?
I guess it could be both. Yeah. You're
right.
So Yeah. Yeah. So this way, we'll still
return the response so you can actually see
what's inside of those error objects, but we're
also returning a non null error object so
that when you're
in main dot go, when you check to
see if the error is not null, we
will actually catch this log that fails. So
now, theoretically,
if I did if I did that right,
we should be able to run this again,
and we should get an actual error. Tada.
I'm only logging in. Ah.
Can we Okay. So Can we always log
the whole request instead of just the data?
Sure. So we can
do a
A response. Sorry. Println response.
Yes. Just so that we can see exactly
what it's complaining about.
Okay.
Nice. So
nice. Yeah. It it looks like it it
returned it returned that, and it's actually gave
us a suggestion.
Yeah.
Something Francis said earlier caught my attention was
that they can get partial returns. So I
was curious of, like, can can we actually
do,
like, one valid and one not valid and
then run it? With is that correct? Yeah.
Oh, okay.
That that would absolutely work. Yeah.
K. Okay. Let's try it.
Yeah. I'll run that and let's see if
no,
I think. Actually, it might be that query
is no on this case because query had
returned an error. But let's find out what
your server does.
Yeah. Let's see what it does. We could
always make surname,
you know,
have a z at the end.
I see. So you know what happened here
is because we
we
oh, yeah. So it does look like it
worked. So we got nothing
for the data,
and then we got an error. So it
does look like it fails
on that part of it and did not
give us partial data back.
So I think let's try this because
this should give us
yeah. I think this would give us what
we want.
Okay.
Should I run that? Yeah. Let's try it.
Alright.
Not
quite.
So this is fast holding. I should also
caveat that this is
a GraphQL server
that generates it based on JSON data with
no types and stuff like that. So it's
not like a fully fledged Apollo GraphQL server.
Probably doesn't have all these bells and whistles.
So maybe this is probably as good as
it's gonna get. You know why it's not
executing? Because it's not a valid query.
There's a query validation step that runs first
to make sure it matches the schema.
Because this doesn't match the schema, it's not.
If you made one of the resolvers throw
an error or say you have a connection
and you can put in some invalid range
or something that will throw an error, that's
when we'll get partial data back. But this
isn't this isn't even executing at all. Your
server's going, you're giving me bad input.
I'll shut you down before I start using
any of my resources.
Okay. That makes sense.
That makes perfect sense.
Alright.
So
if we reformat that to be correct, then
we should be able to run this and
get a good response back. There it is.
Alright.
Very cool.
Alright. So we're gonna oh, I should probably
have a branch for this.
That would be a nice idea. Yeah.
I'm I'm gonna name it Connor. I'm gonna
get name it Rawkode
GraphQL because You need dash b. For Stella.
Oh, yeah. I do need dash b. You're
right.
Nope. That's not a dash.
My typing skills go to hell whenever I'm
on a whenever I'm Francis and I are
getting cooperates
on SPR too, by the way. Just
Uh-huh.
So we'll say basic working
GQL
client with
Rawkode
and Reconbot.
There you go. Nice. Oh, I gotta add
stuff first, though.
Alright.
Hopefully, you won't be able to see my
my password manager pop up with oh, you
we're not even sharing my screen, so we're
good. Nope. I agree. I'm worried about the
terminal.
It seems okay.
Yeah. No. It's it hides it hides it
there.
Cool. Alright. So we have got
the basic one working. So now we'll move
on to the next step, and we wanna
take this Go client that we've created here,
and we wanna expose it as a host
function that can be called
by a,
by a a WebAssembly module. So we're gonna
quickly go back to that capabilities,
struct, and we're gonna add this as one
of the,
available,
capabilities.
Still cannot take that. Forgot about all this.
I was like, hey. We were we made
the client.
Yeah.
So we're gonna set it for the so
there's a function here for default capabilities. So
we're just gonna fill that in in as
well so that, you know, by default, modules
can have that
that GraphQL client available to them.
The nice thing about Reactor is that if
you wanna pass in a custom version of
this struct
to a particular module, you can change it
per module, and that's how you define
which module is able to access which capabilities.
So that's kind of a a neat a
neat part of this. What is Why is
it mad at us? It's
it's mad at us. Oh, because we need
to make this a pointer.
I will I will come back and clean
some of this up later.
Cool. So now we've got this capabilities object
that contains our GraphQL client, and we're gonna
go ahead and expose it to the WebAssembly
modules via a host function. So we're gonna
pop over to the r wasm package, which
contains all of our different host functions.
And I'm gonna create a new file called
API GraphQL,
and that's where we're going to meet. There
we go. So
our wasm is the reactor wasm package,
and we're gonna need to define one of
these functions. So I personally
am just gonna start by copying this one
because it's gonna be somewhat similar.
So we're gonna have this one instead of
fetch URL.
What should we call it?
Query
just query,
I guess. Yeah. GraphQL query? Yeah. GraphQL query.
Yeah.
Alright. GraphQL query. So in Go, you usually
don't use a snake case or kebab case
or whatever you call that. But in the
reactor code base, I like to use the
underscore to define that this is a host
function so that we don't accidentally get confused
later down the line because I know I've
done that a couple of times.
Alright. So for this particular host call, we're
not gonna need a method, so we're gonna
get rid of that one. And but we
are gonna need a URL. But I'm we
in our GraphQL client, we called it an
endpoint, so I'm gonna rename it to endpoint
pointer
and endpoint size.
And then we're gonna wanna be able to
pass that query. So instead of body pointer,
I'm gonna call it query pointer
and query size. So as we talked about
before, this will be the location of the
query in the WebAssembly module's memory, and then
this will be basically the length of that,
memory so that the host can find it.
Now
this identifier is a string.
Yes. It will be a code in a
string. Yeah. Go on. Go on. You're gonna
get to it.
Yeah. So this identifier is something specific to
Reaktor, and this is how we how we
are able to run many, many, many, many
WebAssembly modules all at once is each each
time you execute a WebAssembly module, it's given
an identifier
just so that we know,
you know, which module's memory to go look
at when we're pulling that string out of
the, out of memory.
Alright.
So,
we're going to I guess we didn't implement
it, but how would we do,
variables
with that call signature?
Yeah. You're right. So for,
the this is actually a tricky thing, and
I actually don't particularly love the way I've
implemented this. But in in the HTTP
call, for example, we actually encode
we encode headers for HTTP calls
by, you know, sticking them on the end
of the URL with, like, a custom encoding
that I really
don't like the way that it currently works.
So I'm we're not maybe we won't replicate
that here because I don't wanna continue propagating,
you know, bad practices. It's something that I've
been meaning to improve, and this code is
and
yeah. In in the at Shopify, we've handled
this with message pack. And so
we we just write message pack in and
out. And so you all you're doing is
passing this pointer around
for the string of the input and the
output.
There are limitations there too. And then we
also we started
I don't know if I could talk about
it, but there's a world in which we
might like JSON. And because JSON could parse
real fast in certain locations, and so we're
like, okay. So, you know, maybe it's just
JSON in and out.
Yeah. But that I think there will be
a future version that's based on JSON. The,
the reason I didn't go with JSON in
the first place was that Swift
is one of the languages supported,
by Reaktor,
and working with JSON in Swift in WebAssembly
is actually kinda broken, or at least it
was when I first implemented this. So I
went with a,
less nice but,
worked version than, you know, the the ideal
version.
Cool. So
we're going to gonna come around about eventually,
you think? Hopefully. Hopefully. I'm I'm hoping that,
you know, there will be some kind of
wazzy
proposal that comes out soon that I may
or may not be working on related to
some of these things,
but that's all I'll say for now.
Okay.
Cool. So we're gonna add this little piece
of boilerplate here. So this
this takes the identifier that I just talked
about, and it actually gives us the WebAssembly
instance,
that is associated with that identifier, and it
allows us to actually go in and read
that memory. So
when this host function gets called, we're gonna
find the WebAssembly module associated with the identifier,
and then we're gonna read the memory out
of that instance. So we're gonna do instance
dot read memory,
and we're gonna pass in the endpoint pointer
and the endpoint size,
and that's gonna result in some bytes. So
we're gonna say the endpoint
bytes
is here, and then the endpoint
is the those bytes
converted into a string. So we've taken the
raw WebAssembly memory, and we're gonna convert it
into something that we can actually use with
our GraphQL client.
This can basically
so, theoretically, yes, it can fail, but the
read memory internally has some checks to ensure
that nothing really bad happens.
Cool.
Yeah.
So we're going to do essentially the same
thing
for the query,
and this is going to be with the
query pointer and the query size.
So no. Query size
and then the query bytes. So now we
have basically the two things that our GraphQL
client needs
in order to actually do this properly. Oh,
we
are right. The, let me just import that.
That's why this is complaining.
Hey, Gabriel. We're using, live share.
Yeah. Something that I've never really used a
lot before, and it's really, really cool. It
basically turns Versus Code into Google Docs. It's
really awesome.
It's working.
Yeah. So now,
now that we have the two inputs that
we need, if we go back to our
GraphQL client, we'll remember that we need the
endpoint and the query as the input to
our code that we wrote earlier. So we're
gonna take you know, now that we've read
the endpoint out of the WebAssembly memory and
we've read the query out of the WebAssembly
memory, we're gonna actually make that call. So
we're gonna we're gonna grab the instance. It
has what's called a a CTX or a
context, and this contains
that GraphQL client that we added before. So
this is how capabilities
are passed to the WebAssembly modules. That capabilities
object
gets given to the WebAssembly instance when it's
executed so that we can use those capabilities
in a fun way. So we're gonna call
that do method on it, and we're gonna
pass in our endpoint and our query. Yeah.
This is where the magic starts to happen.
So we're gonna get our response and our
error from that, and I don't wanna call
it error because that would be the type,
not the actual variable name.
And
now another part where WebAssembly is a little
bit challenging and where I think the reactor
code base needs some work done is that
passing those error messages back to the WebAssembly
module is not yet currently possible. So as
kind of an interim solution,
we're gonna use this this logger
object that is available,
to just print the error message,
if if one occurs.
So we can Instead of
yep.
No. So so instead of writing, like, into
a area of memory
that that they've reserved for a response,
something like that? So
yeah. So, eventually, that is the plan.
Reactor just doesn't support that yet.
Okay. But it does support passing back just
the successful response.
So
now we've kind of gotten to the point
where, oh, we're gonna, return,
return a negative one if this happens. So,
because of WebAssembly's limited, you know, ability to
have really complex types, the thing we're returning
here is an int 32.
And,
when an error happens in reactor, we return
a negative number to indicate that it's kind
of similar to bash or or a shell.
When something bad happens, you return, you know,
something,
you know, a nonzero or a negative number
to indicate that something failed.
But if a successful
call happens,
the return value is actually the size of
that response. So it's a bit of a
it's a bit of a tricky little interface
that hopefully, you know, the WebAssembly spec will
make a little bit less complicated over time.
This is like old it's like my c
code.
Yeah. Exactly.
So,
you know, web and that's one of the
one this is basically the reason why I
built reactor was so that it could hide
all of this complexity from you, you could
kind of just use it as a normal
library and not have to worry too much
about it.
Alright. So we're going to continue
copying some of the code from the HTTP
version of this just to speed things along
a little bit, and we're gonna do essentially
this. So what we're gonna do is we're
going to the
response is currently a struct, but we're going
we need to serialize that
into something that can be written into WebAssembly
memory. So we're gonna actually convert that to
JSON
and
write that into the the WebAssembly module. So
we're gonna use that
the response, We'll call it response bytes to
be consistent,
is JSON dot Marshall. Again, we've seen this
before.
And then if the error is not null,
we're going to, do the same thing as
we did up here.
Out of curiosity,
since would it always make sense to
to to write these bytes because
the response is useful on air?
Or is that is that supported return?
So, yeah, that that would Reactor would need
to learn how to do that because, the
negative their negative response code means that we
can't tell it how big that, response is.
Ah, I gotcha. Yes. So, we're what we're
doing is we're converting it to bytes. We're
we're using the set FFI result function to
write those bytes into the module, and then
we're returning the size of those bytes so
that the module can then go and find
it in memory and reconstitute it.
Cool.
Cool. So we have our,
this is our host call, basically. We we've
now defined an interface,
that the WebAssembly module can use to ask
the host to make a GraphQL
query on its behalf. So, we do need
to do one little extra step, which I'm
just gonna, again, copy and paste.
We need to create a wrapper around this
host function to pass to the Go object
of the
WebAssembly instance. So,
this is just boilerplate code.
GraphQL
query, we'll call it, and we have to
tell WebAssembly
the the shape of this function. So,
we have to tell it that, you know,
the what exactly the different arguments are,
so that we can URL.
Yes. You are correct.
So this is endpoints
pointer.
Gabriel, this is gonna run-in Suborbital,
which is a server side framework for executing
Wasm. So it's not gonna run-in a browser.
It's gonna run it's running as
sort of the stateless runnables
in the Suborbital project. Is it suborbital.dev?
Is that the It is. Yeah. Suborbital.dev
is the website. Yeah. So this is the
reactor project, which is
the inside of Suborbital, that is the core
WebAssembly
execution
engine that that Suborbital is built on.
Okay. So we are just creating a tiny
little wrapper here that should
just be two more seconds,
and then we will do the query pointer
and the query size.
So this this wrapper, all it's really doing
yeah. Go ahead. Can I teach you a
trick?
Yeah. By all means. Yeah. You can hit
if you click on a variable and you
hit f two, you get a little rename,
and you can it'll go and rename everywhere.
There you go. That is the fancy stuff
that I come on these streams to learn
about.
Cool. Yeah. So this this, this wrapper is
essentially just,
taking this host code that we've defined and
telling the WebAssembly instance
about it and giving it information.
So,
now that we have these,
and we've passed I just wanna double check
to make sure we've passed the right
things. Is that the real capabilities?
Right? Because, like like, the other capabilities, that's
in Go. But it but, like, it's not
but this one here is the one that
actually gives it to the to the the
host module, right, or the guest module. Yes.
So yeah. So this is given to the
guest module.
This calls our GraphQL query function,
and then the GraphQL query function
grabs our capability to actually perform the the
action. So there's a there's a bit of
a rigmarole that you have to go through,
but that, you know, is what's needed to
make it as flexible as it is.
Cool.
So the last thing we're gonna do is
we're just going to find the random point
in the code where this is all added
to the module. So we're gonna take that
that GraphQL query
wrapper function that we just wrote, and we're
gonna include it in the host functions that
are given to the module. And we should
be pretty much ready to to switch over
to to WebAssembly. So
do we have any any, maybe, comments or
questions we wanna address before we move on?
So
Gabriel did ask if this is gonna run
on a browser, but there was a kind
of a second part of that, which is
why would we use Wasm on the host?
If you got a Yeah. That's that's
a great question. So,
one of the great things about WebAssembly and
and the one of the reasons why I
chose WebAssembly as the technology to power Suborbital
is that you can have
multiple
different languages coexisting inside of the same application.
So the, you know, people who use
Suborbital, they often have different teams within their
company that are comfortable with different languages. So
maybe they'll have, you know, a mobile team
that is used to writing Swift, or they'll
have, you know, a a web team that's
used to writing TypeScript.
And so they can actually write code in
those different languages, and they can all coexist
inside the same server architecture without you needing
to do anything crazy to to make them
communicate with each other.
Okay. We also have a question from YMO,
but I also point out that Noel has
pointed a bug in our code where we
are returning fetch URL
instead of GraphQL query.
Where is that?
Oh, I see. There we go.
Okay. So why am I always asking about
garbage collection?
Specifically,
go and wasm looking at lane 17 to
20, which I think are now 34 onwards.
I'm curious about garbage collecting. Yes. Yeah. That's
right. So
when we flip over to the Suborbital Rust
library, you'll see some of this. But so
WebAssembly itself does not yet have a built
in garbage collecting paradigm. That's, again, one of
this one of the proposals that is currently
being
put through the standards body is a garbage
collecting proposal.
But
the
you know,
currently, the the suborbital
hosts and guest code collaborate together to kind
of do garbage collection.
I don't wanna use the word manually, but
it is kind of manual where, know, the
reactor is telling,
the guest module to clean up memory at
the appropriate time, and then, like, the guests
the guest code
complies and actually does it.
Okay. I just wanna check with you both.
Like, we're at the hour now where we
said we would finish. Do you wanna go
on for another ten to fifteen minutes and
get this working, and is that okay for
both of you? Yeah. I'm cool. Let's go
for it. Yeah. I'm excited. Alright. Awesome. We'll
try to power through the end here. So
yeah. So we're gonna switch over to Rust
now, and we're going to I'll pretend like
I understand everything from here on out.
Hey. I think of the three of us,
David is the Rust guru.
So Oh, no. I'm totally Alright.
So,
you know, once again, we're gonna we're gonna
do some copying and pasting just to make
this go quickly. So we're gonna define
a a GraphQL.
Again, cannot type that word. We're gonna define
the GraphQL
module within the Suborbital library, and we're going
to define
that
that host function
as something available to it. So we're basically
doing the mirrored,
the mirror to the last,
the host call where we're gonna just expose
it here inside of
the
inside of the module. So I think that
should be good. We've got our endpoint pointer,
endpoint size, query pointer, query size ident. Perfect.
Alright. So now we need to
create a
a an actual, you know, usable function that
somebody can go ahead and call. So we're
gonna define a pub f n
f n, and we're gonna just call it
query to keep things simple. And we're going
to take in an endpoint,
which is an STR,
str string. I don't know how people pronounce
that in real life.
And we're gonna take in a query,
which is also an STR,
and we are going to return
probably a result,
I would assume,
of
bytes
of VecU eight
comma
run error, which is a
a suborbital defined type. So
Why wouldn't they wanna JSON parse here?
So we
will to keep things simple, I think the
caller is going to JSON parse
because my
Rust skills of being able to pass in
a struct, parse it, and then all that
stuff, I don't think I'm able to do
that in the next fifteen minutes, so we're
just gonna keep it simple.
Alright. So oh, we need to
I don't know why it's complain oh, right.
We need to actually use the full path
for this. There we go. I think that
should be good.
Yes. Alright. So it's just complaining that we're
not returning at this point. So
we should be able to
do something fairly similar to
this
where we
so we wanna take the
the
endpoint and the query, and we wanna convert
that into memory that can be transmitted to
the host.
So we're gonna try to do this in
a fairly quick fashion. So there's a couple
of helper functions
inside of this library that will make it
a little bit easier for us, and I
just need to find them.
Right. So we're gonna be doing
as slice and as pointer, I believe.
Yeah. Let's just do that.
So
we're going to say that our
our endpoint
slice
is the
endpoint
as a slice.
Of course, that's going to complain.
This is where David might need to help
me here.
Oh,
right. We need to It's already a slice,
isn't it?
You'd think.
The body
is
oh, here's vector.
It's a vector of bytes. Yeah.
So you can So we need to
Sorry. Go. We just need to do
how do you convert a str to a
vec a asvec, I think?
Is that
no. We don't
we don't need that. Right?
Oh. Oh. You you go ahead and take
over.
Why? Oh, there we go. And so we
can get as base, which is gonna be
yeah. You don't want yeah. You don't actually
want a vector. Right? You want the so
just as base We do want a vector.
We do want a vector.
You do you do want a vector?
Yeah. Because the vectors will write into WebAssembly
module.
Yeah. Slice would work.
Okay. And what are we doing with the
pointer?
So that pointer
right. Exactly.
And then we wanna take
query.
That would be the endpoint pointer.
Oh, yeah. Oops.
We're gonna do this twice. Once for the
endpoint, once for the query.
There we go. Alright.
Okay. This is why David this is why
I wanted to do this on the stream.
No. I can't type. There we go.
There we go. Alright. You got it. So
what's the we are yeah. No. So now
we're gonna actually make that host call. So
now we're going to say that the results
we're gonna let
results
size
equal
the
so we're we have to do we have
to use the unsafe directive here because we're
actually calling
something that is being given to us at
runtime, which is, you know, in Rust terms,
something unsafe.
So we're gonna say we're gonna call that
GraphQL
query function.
We are going to pass the endpoint pointer,
and then we're going to do
this would be endpoint
slice dot len, I think. Slice dot len.
Is that yeah. That's valid.
And then query
pointer
and then query
slice dot len.
For some reason, I keep typing zed instead
of c.
And then we're gonna pass in that ident
as
the last parameter,
and that should
cannot find GraphQL query in this scope. Why
not?
Did I misspell it? It looks like it
it does say there's a different
it's hard to do when I'm Sorry, honey.
I'm I'm scrolling around. It's my fault.
Okay. You just kinda spell. Oh,
well, that that would explain a lot. Alright.
Cool.
So alright. We need to convert these to
as I 32
and
as I 32,
and this
cannot find ident in scope. Oh, that's right.
We need to do super
it's a super call.
Super state ident. That's what it is.
Apologies for the copy and paste. I wanted
to do a lot more of this live,
but we are running out of time.
Alright. So we're gonna
think I know this. Semicolon will go at
the end. Okay.
There we go. So now we've called the
host function,
passing it the pointer and length for each
of our two parameters,
and then we're going to take that information,
and we're gonna actually do something fun with
it. So we're gonna use this
this helper function that's included in this library
to accomplish that in a way that's not
super gross.
So we're going to
basically,
read the memory
from the the, you know, that the host
has given back to us and passing that
size as the parameter,
and this is going to give us
either the the bytes or an error. And
so because the return type of this function
is either bytes or error,
this kinda just satisfies it. So I believe
at this point, we have everything that we
need in the in the library. So should
we try to actually
use this thing?
Definitely.
Alright. Hopefully, we can do this in in
a quick five minutes and be done for
the day. Alright. Alright.
So we're gonna create in we're gonna go
inside of this in this test data function
package because that's where I keep all of
my all of my testing stuff. So we're
going to use the
the Suborbital CLI to
create a runnable called,
let's say, r s ref
q l.
Still cannot take that word, and we're gonna
put it inside of our wasm
our wasm
slash
test
data.
I think
that should do it.
Alright. So now we have a new
this is a reactor runnable
that is written in the Rust language,
and we should now be able to take
advantage of that GraphQL function we just wrote
within here. So we need to do a
quick little
trick just to make sure it's importing the
right
version of the library because we wanna use
the local version instead of a version from
the cargo package manager. So we're just gonna
edit cargo dot toml real quick to trick
it into using the local version,
and then we're gonna get to work. So,
hopefully, if it accepts
all of this,
we should
be able to use it.
Hopefully,
cargo dot toml.
Hopefully.
Sometimes I need to restart my my Rust
server in order for it to like that
after I do that import.
External location does not exist.
It seems to like it, but for some
reason, it doesn't.
Well, we're gonna just try it anyway. So,
we are going to,
call.
We're gonna import the
Suborbital
GraphQL.
It knows it's there, so it's obviously just
complaining for no reason.
Let's put something on there. I don't know
why it doesn't like that one, but it
likes this one.
Anyhoo,
so we're gonna call,
query, which is from, like, GraphQL,
one there. Do you wanna fill in the
endpoint
and the query there for me, David, like
you did in the other example, or should
I just copy it?
That's alright.
I think that's right.
Shouldn't I probably have an HTTPS on the
front of that,
I think.
Fussy pants.
And do we need a response? Yeah.
So we need to put that in something.
So that is going to be a result
type. Oh. And so we're probably gonna wanna
match on it.
Yeah.
Time for a speed round.
Don't know where this goes yet. So
It's a response. Right?
What what alright. Okay. Yeah. Response.
Blah.
Yeah.
Definitely print it.
Do we have a logger?
We do have a logger. Yes. We do.
Does print l n work here?
I have no idea. Okay.
Oh, it's okay. I'll I'll fill it in
after that. There you go. So we will
we will we'll use a suborbital log for
this,
which will give us some actual
we're going to,
log in as info, I think, not into
info.
No.
It'd just be info. Yeah. Lowercase.
So we'll just log that help me.
I guess we actually wanna log the the
string version of that response, don't we? So
we'll want to do
response
oh, we want string
from
is that right? Mhmm. Yep.
Well, it depends what response is. It's just
page. Right? So it should be okay. S
j r. Yeah. I think that should work.
It's it's not yelling at me, so that's
that's
that's decent. And then we will log
if we get an error here, we will
log
that ee
dot
e should have a
message,
I think,
if I remember correctly.
Dot message spelled properly, I believe. And an
and an error type. Right?
Or is this your message? Sorry.
This should be
this will be a generic error message because,
yeah, there's not much we can do there.
Alright.
So
it it's only yelling at me up here,
but I feel like that's a fake error
because There's a restart complaining about anything else.
If you pull up your command, you can
restart
Yeah. Okay. What's it called?
Definitely had to do Language server? R l
s. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, it could be that the that it's
that the that the library has an error
because it seems like it does.
Why doesn't it like us here? Do I
have to return here?
No? No. Because there's no semicolon, so we
don't have to return. Although, I was telling
this that we're not returning.
Oh, no. But Right.
It's complaining about a
bunch of different stuff here.
Well, it's complaining that we got the user
size I 32.
We're so close.
We are so close. Yeah. Let me let
me compare it to the other one because
that's how I usually that's how I usually
write code. It's just compared to something that
I've done in the past that worked.
Let's see. It doesn't seem to complain here
about that. We're doing the same thing here.
So I wonder why
this one would be complaining about it.
Does that have a comma? Yeah. There's supposed
to be a comma there.
You restart
the server the language server?
Yeah. Yeah. I just did that. Doesn't seem
to have Let's let's try and just
let's pretend that it returns that.
And then it's complaining about this.
Oh, yeah. If we can just ignore that
now.
Hopefully.
Okay. So now he's only complaining about our
use size and I 32.
Yeah.
Just trying anything.
We do have the I 32. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not sure why it wouldn't like
that.
It says you can only convert it by
doing trying to an unwrapping because that might
view size might be larger than an I
32, so it might panic.
That's strange. What do I do down here?
Yeah. Dot line as I 32. That's what
we do down here.
Did I get that right?
Nothing that found on you said. Okay. Thanks.
Gotta love it when you're right at the
finish line and it doesn't like it.
Yeah.
Well, do we define
the inputs of GraphQL query different than we
do
for the other thing?
So, yeah, our endpoint pointer is a constituent,
and our size is nine thirty two
for each of them. So endpoint pointer is
a
constituent,
which is why it doesn't mind that. But
then for some reason
Okay. Let's try
you said it was potentially a VEX, so
I'm gonna force it.
Mhmm. And what was it a VEXR?
Right?
Yeah.
Enter.
Does that help?
Oh, sorry. I'm scrolling around.
Yeah. Let's see.
When we take
this URL and we convert it, what do
we do here?
We do
URL string as str dot pointer and then
URL string dot link. Why don't we try
just copying
this? Oh, you're you're using uppercase
strings. Right?
Nope. These are
ampersand str. And no. But then the bottom,
you have
this follow thing is I'm gonna turn you
off now.
Yeah. That's still that's okay.
So we'll take
Yeah. You're using format here. Right?
And string from. So these are uppercase strings
that you're using length on and slice.
I see. Okay. Could always do a
string
from
endpoint
and then as
slice.
Why is it complaining about that?
As slice is not a thing. Is that
not what we just done here? Might be.
It might be as back.
URL string.
Oh, no. You're just you're you're just using
a string. Right? Okay. Sorry. Yeah.
And then that has a length as an
I 32.
This is well, that should be endpoint slash.
Right?
Why do computers hate us?
Very, very good question.
So we are trying to pass a pointer
and a length of the endpoint here. Right?
That's that's our mission. Okay. So we've got
the as pointer, which is fine. So I'm
not really sure if we actually need these.
Yeah. Maybe not. If we just do endpoint
dot len. Yeah.
You probably still need an access to the
And I thought it's a new type.
But But it's not it's it's it's it's
still complaining about the new size even though
we casted it.
Okay. So endpoint
size
equals endpoint dot l n. I mean, does
that work?
Let's find out.
Endpoint
size.
Yeah. For some reason, it likes that, but
not the other way around. Alright. So let's
do query
dot as
pointer here, and then we can can you
add the same thing for query there?
Alright.
Oh.
What's it complaining about? Semicolon.
Expect expected that.
Something with my with my I think it's
your language server thing. Right? Yeah. I've restarted
it about four times already.
Can we just compile it? Unfortunately. Yeah. I
think we might be able to. Yeah. That's
that's that's basically what I'm coming to at
this point. So if we try to build
we wanna build our Wasm
slash test data,
right, slash
what is this called?
R s GraphQL
r s GraphQL,
and then we use the native tool chain.
Let's see if it's
complaints.
Why? Oh.
No such failed test data GraphQL.
R wasm
test data r s GraphQL.
Did I misspell that?
K.
Why don't we here. We we can just
build them all.
Easier than trying to do it with an
individual one.
So this is this is just Subor is
gonna go through and build every single piece
of test data, which should only take ten
seconds or so. Yeah. You still can't spell
GraphQL. That's why.
Probably. Yeah. GraphQL
and the path.
My alright. Well, that makes sense.
That is gonna be my legacy from this
stream. It's just my inability to spell the
words GraphQL.
Alright.
Should be just about done here.
I can't wait. I'm just waiting for it.
Oh, yeah. There it is. So now it's
complaining.
Three errors.
Oh, we I know what we did. Oh,
yeah. We're just tostring instead of asstring.
And you've called an
error function in libris.
I'm gonna follow you again.
Oh, I see.
I see. Okay.
Right. We can't use that.
We are going to instead.
Oh, we are
yeah. That's right. We're going to do
we want the error function from the logging
package instead of
the error macro from the yeah. That makes
sense. Okay. So now that I know that
I've misspelled that, let's try to rebuild,
just that one in particular. So if we
build,
our wasm
slash test data slash r s dash g
r a
q h q l because, apparently, that is
that is
how I've done it.
Alright. So it's complaining. Oh, I just passed.
It's just complaining about our inputs there. So
if we
instead of toString, it should be has str,
apparently. And then No. I think it's complaining
about we've got
because response is back, so we're converting it
to a capital string, and then we are
converting that to a str. So
I think
I think that's what it wants.
Okay. Let's try.
Yeah. We'll see.
No.
Oh, that's right. We can't,
I think there's a I have a util
that will help us here.
We can do
util.
It's because we don't know what encoding the
vec is.
Right. We want to string,
and that will be response.
And then we'll do a str from there.
And then message
is apparently something unknown.
E dot message. That should be the one
error. Yeah. That's that's that one should be
okay.
What type is e? Because I'm not I'm
not getting any
e should be a run error.
Okay.
Yeah.
Assuming we've done our yeah. Run error. And
run error's message is an uppercase s string.
So
Right. So that's why, yeah, that should do
it. Okay. Try that.
Hey. There we go. It built. Alright. Hey.
So
now Run it. We should be able to
we should be able to run this module
and actually get something usable. So now we're
gonna switch over
to our the fastest way to get this
running is to just use a Go test.
So
we will
let's find one that's doing this properly. We
will copy this one here,
and we'll create a brand new test
called
oh,
I barely didn't like that. What did I
copy around here?
I wanna copy this whole thing,
and we're gonna create a new test called
tests,
let's say, GraphQL
QL runner with
alright.
So we're going to import the
r s dash g r a.
Make sure I make sure I spell my
typo correctly.
G r a
q h
q l
slash
q h q l dot Wasm. Alright. So
now we're going to pass in
well, it's already running the query the way
that we want. Right? So we don't need
to pass anything into it. We can just
pass in, an empty string there.
And then assuming everything goes correctly,
we should be able to say
print l n,
the
response,
which is an interface type, and we wanna
convert that to bytes.
Would this be the logs?
This would be what it returns. Oh, you
know what? You're right. It's logging, so we
don't really need to actually do anything here.
Okay. Because I don't think we returned. Yeah.
We just returned
hello Hello.
In in the module there. So
we can just do nothing here
and and see
what happens. We're not even gonna use the
response.
Okay. Moment of truth. We're gonna run this.
Cross your fingers. See
what happens.
Will you be able to see that output?
No. Oh, I don't think you can you
you can't see my output. Okay. I'll I'll
run the I'll run the test command manually,
and then you should be able to see
it. So if I switch over to that
terminal, you can see that. Right? Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Cool. So let me just format
this correctly. We're gonna make it verbose, and
we're gonna run the local version.
And
There
it is. Our data.
Hi.
I recognize that name.
Alright.
We did. That was a very long walk,
but we got there in the end.
Awesome. Oh, that's fantastic.
Yeah.
So we're using, yeah, we're using reactor
to load this WebAssembly module that we built,
and then we are calling it,
and that WebAssembly module is making a query
to David's
GraphQL endpoint. That is passing the query to
the host. The host is doing the request,
passing the response back to the module, and
then that is getting logged
by the module. So that was a very
long walk, but we got there in the
end. That's
a beautiful thing.
Yeah. That So so that was super file.
We can, like, delete the Rust, keep that
RUSM file, email it to a friend, and
they can run it. And it would go
and hit API dot Rawkode.dev.
And as long it has the right
capability
functions,
then it would be able to log, do
the GraphQL,
and give us give and give us that
output.
That's alright. Exactly right. So, you
know, when you at the top of the
Rust file, you saw we were importing the
different modules from the Suborbital library, and that
was basically importing those capabilities that we had
written earlier in the stream. So it all
comes together, and and we were we were
able to to conquer the dragon.
It's a beautiful thing. Oh my goodness.
Alright. Well, that was very, very cool. I
really enjoyed that. I learned an absolute ton.
So I'm gonna say thank you, Connor. Thank
you, Francis. It was a pleasure to sit
and work through that with you both. Any
last words?
Yeah. I don't think so. It's a lot
of fun. I'm gonna drop a link for
Gabriel into the Discord chat
about some other capabilities we're doing with Wasm
or people out there are doing with Wasm
where, like, because of the nature of it,
you can, like, boot a program and then
pause it and then and then use it
to execute, you know, input from there. There
there's, like, all these it because it's because
of that isolation, there's this entire world of
things you can do for very fast computing.
And and, you know, and I'm just, like,
like, waiting for a game to install the
other day. And I'm like, if this was
WASM, we could, like, stream it, you know?
Like like like like, I could just start
playing it because it just start reading the
memory from the beginning. Right? You know? Yeah.
We're not in that world yet. And
yeah. And and the portability of it is
awesome. Like, if if a browser were to
expose that same GraphQL query host function, you
could take this exact same Wasm module, run
it in Reactor, and then also run it
in the browser. And that's the portability that
you don't get with any other technology. It's
really quite cool.
Yeah.
Alright. We will leave it there, but we
will fill up the description with more links
to more awesome stuff on Suborbital and others.
Thank you both again. Yeah. Have a wonderful
evening, and hopefully, I'll see you both again
soon. Thanks. Yeah. Cheers. Thanks everyone.
Bye. Have a good day.